it's only a matter of time before we get
nuked before this channel is gone this
channel is de-ranked geez i thought you
meant a real nuke that was terrible
i was about to bring up the aliens it's
only a matter of time before
uh we're suspended because well i mean
think about the things we're talking
about right now
this good stuff these are these are
dangerous conversations the
establishment does not want
google's not the establishment that's
what's cool
it's the most powerful corporation but
the establishment
is competing with them bro did you see
the video of the google employees
crying when they announced trump won and
the ceo and the president all the people
being like we know we know we're going
to resist and make sure it doesn't
happen again
they're the establishment they call me
and they tell me i can't talk about
certain things
they they tell me this like we're
letting you know because we
like you and we want you to play ball
and i have my limits because i think
getting the message out to the best of
my abilities is better than just giving
up
but there's a line and we're getting
dangerously close to it dude we got we
got we got we got big news right here we
got we got to talk about it okay
from fox news twitter to expand covet 19
vaccines policy to combat harmful
misleading tweets
twitter will begin enforcing their
updated policy on misleading tweets
surrounding covet 19
vaccines on december 21st so now
as we've we're getting stories about say
anaphylaxis out of out of alaska and
i've got democrats accusing me
of being an anti-vaxxer for pointing out
a health warning issued by the
government so
even talking about what's true is
considered a threat to these tribalists
we know that twitter is basically
ideologically tribalist left as well
so how long until i see a story that
says
bell's palsy you know people got bell's
palsy after getting the vaccine
they don't think it's significant
because the same amount of people who
get it get it normally or whatever and
whatever the point is what happens if
i'm like wow there's something people
should know
and then someone at twitter says that's
anti-vaxx delete we will use the fervor
to start a new network
well we have to understand if they
really were to enforce this rule
they would have to take down the british
government's ability to publish
information
they would have to be real i i know i'm
being i'm being um
of what actually should happen there's a
big difference between what actually
does happen because again we have to
understand
with the bigger point that i'm trying to
make here that this is a bigger disguise
in order to limit more speech in order
to control people
in order to have just an excuse to
destroy the competition of the
mainstream media
and to destroy the voice of anyone
questioning the establishment
narrative which they are desperately
trying to hold on to
because the only thing these people have
is their propaganda
and it only works if it goes
unchallenged and challenging it
questioning it is becoming more and more
outlawed
more and more dangerous to even speak
about and that's why earlier you saw the
way i started the show
there's a reason there's a reason i gave
you a hand i'm gonna
i'm gonna let you all in on an open
secret
the only reason this show exists is
because youtube allows it to you know
it and it's not it's not because you do
it it's not just about us getting banned
it's about the fact that 80 of views for
all of my channels come from youtube's
recommendations
that's it my views would probably be in
the tens of thousands
based off of people who actually want to
seek out and watch my content
but most people between it's it's
between 68 depending what the content is
are not subscribed and when they see it
they'll go to youtube.com and youtube
will say
watch this video if youtube at any point
decided
this conversation is over it is
because regular people are only getting
it because they're seeing it in their
recommendations and this is
absolutely wild because if you look at
our conversations we are trying to be
careful
we're trying to tell you both sides of
the story we're trying to
be as fair and as honest as we can and i
think
you know i don't want to you know i i
don't think we could even compare
ourselves to the mainstream media which
is
bloodthirsty for power yeah yeah here is
mainstream now well dude
we this this channel gets like 20
million views per month and cnn gets
210 million they're both mainstream
a lot of those are airport views though
no no cnn's this is like a six-man
operation this is insane it's awesome
but also we have to understand uh the
tables are tilted towards youtube's
uh playing favoritism towards youtube
because everything
you search always comes so let me let me
just say everybody listening right now
if you really do think we're doing a
good job and what we talk about is
important please consider
sharing the link whenever you can
because you know i bring up the
recommendation thing and i see it
there have been periods where youtube
had these glitches glitches i'll do air
quotes
where people were like tim your video
isn't appearing
on your channel people just couldn't
watch it at all
so i it and it happens and it was funny
because i remember what the video was
but it was very much
like i think it had to do with the cia
and trump or something and it just
didn't appear just
how strange was that and i had no idea
why yeah and so i had to
uh i deleted it and re-uploaded it and
then it was there an hour later
very very strange could be a problem but
there's a lot of strength
you know could be a bug but i think it's
like listen if if i put up content
and randomly one day something weird
happens yeah you know maybe it's a bug
when it's the one video talking about
some serious
political still might be a bug i know
personally it still might be a bug
but it's it's it's it's a question of
you know
not to be too conspiratorial we know for
a fact youtube throttles
they tell us they do they have
de-ranking mechanisms
it was nerd city i believe he's a
youtuber you guys check him is really
great
he he found i guess these codes embedded
in youtube's
if you didn't if you search the source
like the inspect source on the page
you would find these codes that would
pop up and they were able to find out
that they were like d rank mechanisms
so we know it exists we do if youtube
wants
they can make it so that people don't
get notifications and
oftentimes they don't and then when
people don't get notifications they
eventually start to forget they stopped
watching that
when we start doing our own network
that's like shortwave radio
slash mesh network bypassing it's going
to be so
we've got the proprietary website coming
soon very very soon it's being built
right now
and that's going to be where we do our
best to make sure like if you really are
a big fan of the show you come in and
you can watch there and you can get
stuff there and even if we get nuked
we'll still exist but i'll tell you this
man
youtube is the town hall the city square
all that stuff and people are going
youtube.com
they're walking in and looking at this
field and what's happening is there's
people everywhere yelling and talking
about a bunch of stuff
and youtube is going check out these
ones these are big these are cool
and that helps us that helps this show
but at any point they could be like you
guys get out dude yeah but then we're
relegated to
you know our little wacky shack a couple
miles away and we're holding up besides
saying guys guys we're still over here
viewership will be dramatically
decreased video revenue will be i mean
look what you know
but jones gets a ton of views on that
video yeah
one of the few exceptions but i've been
telling my audience
you know i love you guys thank you so
much for sharing my videos because if
you didn't
no one else would be watching them and
we would be foolish to think that the
algorithm
isn't used in a way that benefits
a lot of the special interests youtube's
got us in a trap it's a trick let me
tell you the trick
when i look at some of these podcasts so
so
let me tell you we are ranked on itunes
on this show uh tim castrol is ranked i
think like
right now i think it's like one or like
211 or maybe 176 it changes every single
day
and then my main podcast is like was
that ranked 34
top itunes charts at one point now it's
down to like 1 30 something
based on the amount of traffic we're
getting to these shows we should be some
of the wealthiest podcasters
but we're not doing what all of these
other podcasts are doing
what's really interesting is there are
podcasts that have a
tenth of the viewership but everybody
pays five bucks a month so you get
somebody on twitch one of these high
profile lefties
and they have they have a hundred
thousand followers but half of them are
giving five bucks a month these people
are millions that's pretty badass
because that's like
10 cents per show or 20 15 cents per
show that's what that's
that's what i i was thinking like
youtube's got us in this trick where
they're like stay on this platform we do
the youtube rev for you
but don't you say the wrong thing and
i'm like okay we need both
we need we need a proprietary platform
that's what we're going to build
that way people can can can support
directly and then we can start to rival
some of these bigger networks and do
better productions and get bigger
and then we can't you know we can avoid
the bands and stuff like that well i
think
right now that's why youtube just
instituted a new policy even if you're
not
in the partner program or have been
kicked out of the partner program
they could still run ads on your channel
yep without sharing any other revenue
and i i mean my channel is fully out of
the program fully demonetized they were
supposed to
review me in a month it's been i think
over eight months now
of course it's it's making me scramble
and think of other ways to make ends
meet
but you know that's why you know the
t-shirts and did other things but
essentially down the line we have to
understand that this is something that's
affecting everyone because they
enticed everyone with this amazing
utility this amazing tool
they were like you know very smart drug
dealers that give you just a sample
of that crack for free when you're down
and out and then the crackhead takes a
little bit of crack and then essentially
they become a full-blown
partner program and become addicted to
it and then they have no other way
no other avenue to express themselves or
do anything without that constant hint
of validation that youtube provides
i've got a very very important super
chat as we now go to super chats that
just came in and it's very very
important and convenient
and this is from eight o'clock it's from
an hour and a half ago morgan h said i
think tim is being shadow banned
i normally get a notice as soon as the
event is announced but tonight i had to
come look for it
that's what i'm saying so there's a lot
of people
who who watch simply because they got
recommended this and they're like oh
what's this and i'll come and click it
and there's a lot of people who are like
i like to watch the show every night
but if youtube decides it we just don't
exist on the platform anymore
viewership is gone and i'll tell you
this we're in a position right now it's
rather dangerous
that without that recommendation the
show doesn't generate enough revenue to
to actually
exist that's why we got to do this
proprietary website where where you know
there are some podcasts that are like
ranked 7
000 in the world or 10 000 in the world
and i'll let you in on the secret
these are podcasts that get like 10 000
downloads per episode
that sounds like very very little to a
lot of people especially people watch
youtube videos
my youtube videos get half a million so
to look at a podcast on itunes getting
10 000
these people are millionaires no joke
they're millionaires
so i i tell you like the youtube is a
trick you know the real key is to make
sure you're actually running a business
totally and getting customers and fans
and and working with them and producing
content for them and you can pay like
extra to get the behind this or like
we're going to we're going to go pros in
the skate shop
we're building a skate shop so we're
building a skate shop we've got so many
rooms to put
we're gonna have events and we're gonna
we're gonna do uh one of the things
we're gonna do is we're gonna have bonus
uh member segments for the website
so that way you know like everything we
do now we do super chats but we've got a
couple more stories we never get into
right we got some
some creepy ones we mentioned early on
we might not get to and that's something
we'll be like okay if we didn't get to
it then we're going to put it on the
site for
you know the people who want to be
members and we'll have merchandise and
discounts and all that stuff
because that's the way we got to do it
if we want to make this a big network
and survive beyond what youtube is
but more importantly once we get this
side up here's the best part
we're going to have segments for members
only where we get spicy
where we can stay talking about youtube
will not let us say where luke can go
off the rails and scream about the
aliens
and the nordic
i have a lot to say i've been uh
stopping myself from expressing it
i'll be swearing but there's names just
for no reason
just as much as i can but think about
that all of it
the risk we were put under for simply
one of alex jones on the show
yeah they they took a show that was so
sick and that was like one it was like
two million
go to [ __ ] shoot and find it you guys
because that show was happening millions
it was cool
and we can up re-upload it on our new
platform once we get uh
yep we could probably translate all the
episodes onto the new platform
have everything there but we're going to
start doing the clips on youtube
the ultimate spicy segments you know and
then the silly segments too
and really just say whatever we want and
laugh and and and
it's it's crazy because you can't even
make jokes on youtube i'm like
draining my mind as we sit here yep so
this is what youtube wants
and i told him this i was like you guys
are forcing us
all the creators to make something of
our own now i know a lot of people point
out other platforms they're like why
don't you go on patreon why don't you go
on on locals why don't you go on mines
locals is a million times better than
patreon no doubt
but you still don't want to be under
someone else's conclusions and the isp
is a bit
concerning but they're not is hardcore
you really got to go and do
crazy stuff to get the isps involved but
we're ahead and we're
we're heading into that maybe that's why
like mesh networking we need
something like the fetiverse we need
decentralized social media
that's what we really need and and and
people have tried to do it for a long
time but
we need a free and open internet like
the original
internet before it was squeegee cleaned
by the corporate
globalist the original internet was wild
west man i loved it people were doing
crazy nonsense you know somewhere on the
deep on the dark web the deep web
there's a there's an animation of you
know macho man randy savage doing the
banana dance
cities on a geo city somewhere the dark
web is something crazy i've never gone
to the dark web and i don't
maybe the dark the dark apparently it's
in another internet that's that's
underneath the internet yeah but that
just means
stuff there no no no no no no it just
means not indexed wait it's
not the darkness that i think of the
dark knight yeah the dark net and the
deep web are the same thing okay and
it's a reference to
non-indexed that's where like the silk
road was
that was the onion network yeah tor
right that's that's different the onion
router
right so those were that that was a
different or is a browser that you use
to access that stuff without being found
out yep well maybe trump will pardon uh
ross uh
well there's uh there was a daily beast
article according to two of their
sources allegedly anonymous sources but
they say
that they're inside of the white house
that trump is uh considering pardoning
ross
ulbricht and is favorable to that idea
and if that's
true i mean that would be huge i know
ross's mother ross's mother gave me the
first interview ever
publicly speaking about what actually
happened to ross and her story is
absolutely incredible
uh her uh the way that that everything
the government said was happening with
ross turned out to be absolutely not
true the amount of lying the amount of
disinformation surrounding this case
will make your head
spin wow and uh yeah check out lynn
albrecht and maybe if you put in we are
change you'll be able to see our
interview
i interview her at least once a year she
gives us updates about this case
but she's been trying to get ross's name
out there to the general public for
a while because if you essentially look
at that case
the main legal argument against him is
that he ran a website that other people
did something
bad on which if that's the case then
mark zuckerberg should definitely be in
jail too
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you